toss a coin to your new Witcher if
you've been struggling to imagine Liam
Hemsworth as geralt of Rivia some
stunning new fan artist here to help
when The Witcher premiered on Netflix in
late 2019 fans of the popular novels and
video games were treated to largely
faithful storytelling and an accurate
visual representation of the source
material the series Tells A Tale of
Garrosh the namesake Witcher a lover of
baths and Slayer of all manner of gnarly
beasts although some fans felt season
1's multiple timelines made it
needlessly confusing the show has
received generally good reviews for its
CGI acting and the second season that
many fans felt was a clear improvement
over the first it took me to the fourth
verse to understand there are different
timelines not magic kiss that was a bit
cheap yeah season three of The Witcher
has been filmed but with the news that
Henry Cavill is being recast with Liam
Hemsworth as geralt for season four many
fans are both displeased and
apprehensive about the show's future the
English actor embodied the role with the
commanding presence humor and Charisma
that he has become known for so it is
only natural for viewers to feel
disappointments once Young that they are
familiar with exits a program but with
some fun art already bringing Hemsworth
to life as geralt the future looks
promising Digital Arts destroy Ledger
shared an image on his Instagram page
that gives fans a fun preview of what
the Australian actor could look like in
the part with Gerald's signature yellow
eyes and White's hair and beard
Hemsworth appears to fit the bill
Hemsworth left fans know on Instagram
that he's pumped to portray geralt in
season 4 and Beyond posting in part as a
Witcher fan I'm over the moon about the
opportunity to play geralt of Rivia I'm
truly excited to be stepping into The
Witcher World despite his excitement fan
discourse has mixed with much of the
dismay stemming from cavalls leaving the
parts so many have become familiar with
through him over on Reddit one fan
posted well at this point after seeing
Henry who can say anyone else will ever
be right for this role another fan
reaffirms the sentiments by replying
honestly at this moment there's no actor
on this planet that is right for geralt
except kavo like his predecessor Liam
Hemsworth is no stranger to action
adventure movie franchises
[Music]
see you again
the Australian actors started scale
Hawthorne in The Hunger Games franchise
in addition to lead roles in
Independence Day Resurgence and the duel
in his Instagram post Hemsworth shouted
out Cavill acknowledging that he has big
boots to fill Henry Cavill has been an
incredible Garrosh and I'm honored that
he's handing me the reins and allowing
me to take up the white Wolf's blades
for the next chapter of his Adventure
Henry I've been a fan of yours for years
and was inspired by what you brought to
this beloved character meanwhile
Hemsworth received a seal of approval
from the Man of Steel star himself on
Instagram cavalshed in my set The
Fantastic Mr Liam Hemsworth will be
taking up the mantle of the white wolf